>> Bret: THANKS.
SEE YOU.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
♪
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
JUST MOMENTS AGO SAN FRANCISCO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BROOK JENKINS
ANNOUNCED MORE CHARGES FILED
AGAINST PAUL PELOSI'S ALLEGED
ATTACKER DAVID DEPAPE.
>> THE CHARGES THAT WE ARE
FILING TODAY INCLUDE ATTEMPTED
MURDER, RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY,
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON,
ELDER ABUSE, FALSE IMPRISONMENT
OF AN ELDER, AS WELL AS THREATS
TO A PUBLIC OFFICIAL AND THEIR
FAMILY.
>> Jesse: THAT'S IN ADDITION TO
THE FEDERAL CHARGES THAT CAME
DOWN EARLIER TODAY FOR
KIDNAPPING AND ASSAULT.
DEPAPE COULD SEE MAXIMUM
SENTENCES OF UP TO 50 YEARS IN
PRISON JUST ON THE FEDERAL
CHARGES ALONE.
FBI SPECIAL AGENT STEPHANIE
MINOR IS THE ONE LEADING THE
INVESTIGATION.
AND EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
EARLY MORNING NIGHT OF THAT
ATTACK.
TODAY SHE RELEASED A CRIMINAL
COMPLAINT.
THAT'S REALLY LEFT US WITH A LOT
OF QUESTIONS.
ACCORDING TO THAT COMPLAINT,
POLICE RECEIVED A CALL AT
2:23 A.M.
PAUL PELOSI WAS ALLEGEDLY
SPEAKING IN CODE.
SAYING THERE WAS A MALE INSIDE
HIS HOME.
POLICE SCANNERS SHOW THAT PAUL
REFERRED TO DEPAPE AND HIS
FRIEND WAS DAVID.
>> STATED THERE IS A MALE IN THE
HOME AND THAT HE IS GOING TO
WAIT FOR HIS WIFE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHO THE MALE IS
BUT HE ADVISES THAT HIS NAME IS
DAVID.
HE IS HIS FRIEND.
SOUNDED SOMEWHAT CONFUSED.
>> Jesse: WAS THAT PAUL SPEAKING
IN CODE?
PERHAPS.
8 MINUTES LATER POLICE SHOW UP
TO THE PELOSI'S HOUSE.
POLICE KNOW PELOSI'S HOUSE THEY
KNOW THIS IS A HIGH PROFILE
RESIDENCE AND THEY KNOCKED ON
THE DOOR.
THE COMPLAINT SAYS, QUOTE:  WHEN
THE DOOR WAS OPENED, DOESN'T SAY
BY WHO, PELOSI AND DEPAPE WERE
BOTH HOLDING A HAMMER WITH ONE
HAND AND DEPAPE HAD HIS OTHER
HAND HOLDING ON TO PELOSI'S
FOREARM.
THE COMPLAINT SAYS THIS PELOSI
GREETED THE OFFICERS WHEN THEY
CAME IN AND THEN OFFICERS THEN
ASKED THEM WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND DEPAPE RESPONDED EVERYTHING
WAS GOOD.
BUT IT ALL WENT SOUTH WHEN
OFFICERS ASKED BOTH PELOSI AND
DEPAPE TO DROP THE HAMMER THEY
WERE FIGHTING OVER.
ACCORDING TO THE COMPLAINT
THAT'S WHEN DEPAPE SWUNG THE
HAMMER INTO PAUL'S HEAD.
THE OFFICERS AT THE SCENE THEN
RESTRAINED HIM.
THE COMPLAINT SAYS POLICE LATER
FOUND DEPAPE FOUND THE BACKPACK
BY THE REAR ENTRANCE OF THE
HOUSE.
INSIDE OF IT TAPE, ROPE, ANOTHER
HAMMER, YEP, ANOTHER HAMMER, AND
A PAIR OF RUBBER AND CLOTH
GLOVES AND A JOURNAL.
WHETHER THEY ASKED DEPAPE WHAT
HE WAS THERE TO DO.
DEPAPE SAYS HE JUST WANTED TO
TALK TO NANCY AND, QUOTE:  IF
NANCY WERE TO TELL DEPAPE THE
TRUTH HE WOULD LET HER GO.
AND IF SHE LIED HE WAS GOING TO
BREAK HER KNEECAPS BY BREAKING
HER KNEECAPS, SHE WOULD THEN
HAVE TO BE WHEELED INTO CONGRESS
WHICH WOULD SHOW OTHER MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS THERE WERE
CONSEQUENCES TO ACTIONS.
WHICH GOES TO SHOW YOU JUST HOW
CRAZY THIS GUY IS.
HE WASN'T THERE TO KILL HER.
HE WAS THERE TO KNEECAP HER AND
WHEELCHAIR HER IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS.
HOW A HOMELESS GUY WAS GOING TO
GET THE HOUSE SPEAKER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO WASHINGTON WITH
BROKEN KNEECAPS, WE DON'T KNOW.
AS ALL OF THIS IS COME IN.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING A LOT MORE
ABOUT DAVID DEPAPE AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN FROM CANADA.
THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE CHIEF
SAYS D HE EPAPE HAD A SLEW OF
FELONY CONVICTIONS INCLUDING ONE
OF ELDERLY ABUSE.
SO HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DEPORTED
BUT SANCTUARY STATE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANKS TO GAVIN NEWSOM AND MANY
OTHERS.
SO HE WAS ALLOWED TO STAY IN SAN
FRANCISCO A TACK THE PELOSIS.
ACCORDING TO HIS STEPDAUGHTER,
DEPAPE WOULD PHYSICALLY AND
SEXUALLY ABUSE HER AND HER
SIBLINGS SINCE THEY WERE VERY
YOUNG SO HE IS ALSO AN ALLEGED
PEDOPHILE.
LOCALS TOLD THE "NEW YORK POST"
THAT DEPAPE WAS LIVING IN A
YELLOW BUS PARKED IN FRONT OF
HIS EXENS HOUSE SAN FRANCISCO
NUDIST WHO IS BEHIND BARS FOR
TRYING TO KIDNAP A 14-YEAR-OLD
BOY.
AND HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND DESCRIBED
DEPAPE A PROGRESSIVE A FAN OF
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO WAS
ALWAYS MORE ON THE LEFT THAN ON
THE FAR RIGHT.
NEIGHBORS SPOKE TO JOURNALIST
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER.
>> THEY ARE JUST, YOU KNOW,
NUDIST DRUG ABUSERS, AND THAT'S
WHO GRAVITATES TOWARDS THEM.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY THEIR
POLITICS ARE?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THEY ARE
MORE LEFT-LEANING.
NOTHING THAT THEY BELIEVE IN
ALIGNS WITH THEIR ACTIONS.
SO THEY WILL SAY THAT THEY ARE,
YOU KNOW, PRO-BLACK LIVES AND
THEN THEY WILL CALL THE POLICE
ON BLACK PEOPLE.
>> WE THINK HE IS THE FATHER OF
SOME OF THEM?
>> NOT SURE AFTER THE ALL BUT IF
HE IS, THEIR MOM TOLD ME THAT
THERE WAS ABUSIVE NATURE IN
THEIR FATHER SO IF IT IS HIM,
THEN HE HAS ABUSED HIS OWN
CHILDREN.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
SO, PEOPLE ARE SAYING DEPAIN WAS
AN OBAMA DEPAPE WAS OBAMA.
HE WAS TAKING A DRUG THAT MADE
HIM IMAGINE INVISIBLE FAIRY
FRIENDS.
OFTEN RANTED ON HIS BLOGS ABOUT
NOT BEING ABLE TO BUY A FAIRY
HOUSE WITH DOORS.
THIS GUY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN A MENTAL
INSTITUTION OR AT LEAST BEHIND
BARS FOR HIS PREVIOUS FELONIES.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ANYWHERE
NEAR THE PELOSI'S HOUSE.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED THAT NIGHT.
HOW DID THIS HOMELESS, DRUG
ADDICT EVEN GET INSIDE THE
HOUSE?
NO ONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO GIVE US
A STRAIGHT ANSWER ABOUT THAT.
NOW, THERE WAS GLASS BROKEN AT
THE REAR DOOR, WE HAVE SEEN
THOSE PHOTOS, BUT THERE LOOKS
LIKE THERE IS GLASS ON BOTH
SIDES INSIDE AND OUT.
AND FBI SOURCES ARE TELL
"PRIMETIME" THAT'S ODD.
IF THE GLASS DOOR WAS SMASHED
IN, WHY DIDN'T PELOSI'S ALARM GO
OFF?
RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE CHIEF SEEMS TO BE SAYING.
MAYBE HE DIDN'T HAVE AN ALARM OR
PUT IT ON.
>> HOW EXACTLY WERE POLICE
CALLED TO THE HOUSE?
WAS THERE A 911 CALL MADE OR WAS
THERE AN ALARM TRIGGERED.
>> NO.
THERE WAS A 911 CALL MADE.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT THERE AND
THANK GOODNESS THERE WAS A 9 # 1
CALL MADE.
>> Jesse: IT LOOKS LIKE PAUL
PELOSI, MULTI MILLIONAIRE IN HIS
HOUSE ALONE UNARMED IN SAN
FRANCISCO DURING A CRIME WAVE
DIDN'T HAVE AN ALARM SYSTEM OR
WASN'T SETTING HIM ALARM SYSTEM.
AND THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
THAT THEIR HOUSE HAS BEEN
ATTACKED BACK IN 2012.
NANCY'S HOME IN NAPA WAS BROKEN
INTO AND BURGLARIZED ON ELECTION
DAY.
AND JUST LAST YEAR RADICAL
LEFTISTS SPRAY PAINTED HER
GARAGE DOOR AND LEFT A BLOODY
PIG'S HEAD ON THE DRIVEWAY.
PELOSIS HAVE CAMERAS ALL AROUND
THEIR HOUSE.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY FOOTAGE FROM
ANY OF THEM NEIGHBORS HAVE
CAMERAS.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY FOOTAGE.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN BODY CAM FOOTAGE
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING.
ONLY THING WITNESSED BEFORE THE
BREAK-IN IS A PRIVATE SECURITY
OFFICER WHO WAS WORKING NEARBY
NOT FOR NANCY BUT FOR A
NEIGHBOR.
WORRY TOLD BY THE FBI.
AND ACCORDING TO THIS FBI
COMPLAINT.
HE SAYS HE SAW SOMEONE CARRYING
A LARGE BLACK BAG WALKING NEAR
PELOSI'S RESIDENCE.
HE SAID HE HEARD HE HEARD WHAT
SOUNDED LIKE BACKING AND SIRENS
WITHIN A MINUTE OR TWO.
WHEN DEPAPE DID BREAK IN THE
COMPLAINT SAYS HE WENT UPSTAIRS
AND CONFRONTED PAUL.
INSTEAD OF TYING THEM UP PELOSI
USE THE BATHROOM WHERE PAUL
PELOSI ENDED UP CALLING THE COPS
AND SPEAKING CODE.
DEPAPE DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A VERY
CRAFTY CRIMINAL, DOES HE?
SURE THERE'S THE BATHROOM.
TWO MANAGED TO GO DOWNSTAIRS AND
OPEN THE DOOR FOR POLICE WITHIN
THE NEXT 8 MINUTES, AGAIN, THE
COMPLAINT SAYS THE DOOR WAS OPEN
BUT DOESN'T SAY BY WHO.
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY JENKINS
WOULDN'T TELL US EITHER.
>> SO AT THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR
WHICH OF THE MEN OPENED THE DOOR
AND WE ARE ALSO STILL FLUSHING
OUT HOW MANY TIMES HE WAS STRUCK
IN THE HEAD.
>> WHY WON'T POLICE SAY WHO
OPENED THE DOOR?
INSTEAD, THE COMPLAINT SAYS
PELOSI GREETED POLICE OFFICERS
GREETED AND THEN WENT BACK TO
WRESTLING OVER A HAMMER.
HMMM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED THAT
NIGHT BECAUSE WE WEREN'T THERE
AND POLICE HAVEN'T RELEASED ANY
FOOTAGE, BODY CAM SURVEILLANCE,
NOTHING AND SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICIALS CONFUSION ABOUT THE
HAMMERS IF THERE WAS A THIRD
PERSON WHO OPENED THE DOOR.
BUT IF WE HAVE LEARNED ANYTHING
ABOUT